Kerchunk!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
and welcome back to SCP Containment breach.
Now, I know it's been a while since the last episode,
so let me get you caught back up.
We       JUHahahHAhaHAHaST     contained Radical Larry
and again I apologize for the delay
It's like, three different games that I really wanted to play suddenly came out all at once
but I intend to get back into the series that I always wanted to play, right soon.
So!
With that being said, we're gonna dive back into this terrible, terrible world
and you can see, he's in there!
He's in that horrible box of death and destruction with that other...
...person...
I'm going to assume that they're dead now, because that would be merciful.
But I don't think that Radical Larry can transfer
into his pocket dimension
Which is where he pulls you into if he actually makes contact with you.
So I'm just assuming, I'm just assuming that everything is hunky dory with that.
And we're gonna be okay.
But I don't remember where we are exactly, because, again, it's been a while.
So I can't recall if Radical Larry is now gooood and we're happy with that,
or if there's some other horrible entity here that we need to deal with.
'cause there is....
wait...
lemme just double check because I need to know if you're-- ok.
So there is this elevator
and I think at the bottom of this elevator was the horrible monstrosity known as the 'Plague Doctor'
that wanted to turn me into one of his zombies
by giving me the "cure."
so we're gonna see if he was all legit about that
and we're gonna go down and meet him again
because I
*gasp*
oh no...
*whispering*
*whispering gets closer*
N N No no no no no no no no no NOOOOOOOOOO
How can i get by?
NO NOO!
Ah fucking-
NOOOO!
*Elevator dings*
NOOOOOO!
Naoooooo
OH GOD NO
AHH!
Ahhh fUCKING WHAT THE FUCK!
Are you kidding?!
Oh god...
HELP ME!
HELP!
MEEEE!
Ow. Oh.
*Blows Rasberry*
Well...
i didn't do well there
Oh ho ho kay
alllright.
So apparently
Mr. Señor plague doctor sure found it easy
to call that elevator back down and poke me with his little finger  and i was donezo right then and there
and i dont think im gonna be able to run around him so
ring around that posie pocket full of fuck you
And then go to hell and die god dammit
O.K.
soo the next thing we need to do
is we need to go in a different direction
because that elevator is full of shit. and what the fuck is going on there
what is any of that?
i have no idea
we really only have one way to go and its to go back through these areas here but i do have to mindfull beca-
ho i thought i put on the wrong one for a second there i didnt want to go to that world
unless maybe i do
unless there is a reason for me to go in that world but i dont think there might be just yet
so i'm gonna keep moving forward
with no ability to be found here and also
i wonder what the hell is down there
cause we got all these
ways to go that dont exactly show us
the right paths all the time
can i CAN I close the god damned door
thank you.
Hi.
where am i now... ok
hello
AHHH good still on top of me are they,
where the hell are--
*muffled crying*
WELLL i think i just found out where you are.
OK
So long as i keep my head
the fooooOOOOOHHH
Why Are you down there?!?!
Why are you down theeeerrreee????
Why are you down there?? and what are you doing???
Am I able to see his face from here?
I'm just wondering what hes doing down there, and how he got there!?!?!
Why he keeps walking into a wall-all...creep a like
All right just gonna ignore that
Just gonna ignore that one
Anyone else here? Okay
So we've figured out where he was!
The crying bitch-baby is down in the pit!
Bein' a 'lil BITCH
Hhoooo
Whose nearby?
Okay, we're fine.
#049 is creeping around, but we knew that.
Okay.
So, there's gotta be another way to go here.
There's gotta be another elevator that I can take...
... Because if there's NOT
Then I'm kinda SKWUOOED, ain't I?
I'm just a little bit skwooooed
Oh.
OH WAIT. No, no.
Is this the elevator that- *clank*
Call the elevator.
*Clank* ohhHH I don' like this!
I DON LIKE DIS
oKAY
Alright, Imma trust you!
We're gonna go down 'ere.
We're gonna have a good ol' time!
And there's not gonna be a Plague Doctor.
Where am I?
Oh no
No, no, no, no, no.
Where am I?
I really hope this-- OHH
IT DID IT DID IT DID IT DID IT DID IT DID
IT DID
OKAY
I GOTTA GET OUTTA THIS ELEVATOR AS SOON AS I GET INTO IT!
FUCKING HELL. That doesn't help anybody at all!
Goodbye!
Fuckin' asshole.
Now, what is this?
Oh, is this just one of those--
"Place your palm on the scanner.
DNA does not match known sample.
ACCESS DENIEEZED!"
Alright.
Oh.
Hi.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Uhhh
Alright then...
WHY IS UHHHhh....
WHY IS BILLY JUST STANDING OVER THERE IN THE DARKNESS?
Billy?
I'm gonna close this door on you because fuck you!
Oh!
That's the way to the computer room!
That's what I need!
OHHhhhKay that was a long blink..
Alright.
See, you're there.
Now, what's this?
Ohh!
The omega warhead silo.
Tha-ha-hat's just a little thing.
Alrighty, then.
Hang on a second here.
Uhh, Dr.L's note.
"'Aversion to light' my foot. He doesn't mind light,
he's never had any issue with light, never, ever, NEVER!
He just doesn't like to talk all at once, no, not at all, not at all.
It..- there were tests done during a breach, some girly item... that could see things.
She watched it, saw it, was seen, saw?
He likes to hurt,  or maybe he likes..- he just likes.
He doesn't retreat from the light, he just stops being 'it' for a while.
He slides back, and hides, and counts to ten again.
Begin again, and off he goes!
Only nobody is ever 'it' again.
He takes his toys, and the players, and he goes home.
Okay.
I'm gonna do down... I'm gonna go down into the Omega Warhead Silo,
Cause that's a hunky-dory, fun place to go with a NUKE!
That could blow us all into ruins(?)
But that's a whole 'nother story; ok...
Hello!
Ooh, I hear you creepin' around up there!
Is you not happy about me being here?
Ok, I don't think I'm gonna set it off
Unless I can save, and show you guys what that's all about
But...
If I can- gonna close that off-
maybe, just maybe- oh, no, can't save, I don't think I'm gonna blow everybody here
let's see, drop that...
pick this up...
Oh!
"Alpha Warheads- four 1 kiloton hydrogen bombs designed to demolish the area above the facility-
-without causing major damage to the underground parts."
Ah, ok, blast shield
Wait...
Oh, that's right!
The Alpha warheads, and then the Omega warheads
Th- It's the difference between four 1 kiloton hydrogen bombs,
and then a 5 megaton hydrogen bomb, designed to demolish everything within a 5 mile radius
requires 5-- O5 level authorization
So if I wanted to-
If I wanted to, I could just blow us all to shit,
Or... wait, no,
They're actually already turned on...
I feel slightly encumbered, but that's okay, because now I got a bulletproof vest, which is good
So if I wanted to
I could turn these off- that's right!
One of the endings, if I turn this off, if Containment cannot be reset, they will detonate these warheads
So...
I'm gonna turn 'em off
Cause at least I can't blow us all to smitheroons
And I think...
I think...
that's what the computer wanted me to do in the first place
That's right!
Oh... alright,
Just need to make sure that-
No Billy's gonna be th- ehhhh, okay, alright,
No, ah, no uninvited guests in the elevator, please
Gonna blink blonk before I get in there
Hello?
Shplink shplonk
Ok, you're still here, apparently
somewhere- oh, ah! Ah!
Ah, where are you?
Oh, where are you- AH! NO! NO!!
Memory access violation- okay, I deserve that.
You need to trust it [x4]
You need to trust, you need to trust, I need to trust what?
What do I need to trust? Are you talking about the computer?
You talking about the computer? Oh, this computer?
"An Exidy Sorcerer microcomputer build in 1978" that has Artificial Intelligence!
Ok, so Billy's in here-
maybe, wait, am I going the right way?
Yeah, I'm going the right way
Alright, so Billy's over here somewhere
simbedy somewhere over here
I think on the other side of this door
oh!
yeah- oh, I see you over there
ok, you are over there, right?
yes, you are, alright,
blink blonk!
no...
blink
shplink shplonk, ok, you come over here, huh?
How 'bout that? Yeah! You want some of me?
Eh- that's too close
Why is this door locked?
Shplink shplonk! Eh, that's too close
Shplink! Oh boy, ok
I'm watching you!
Wazowski
aaaaalways waaaatching
Alright, so now I've got him behind two doors
I'm far enough away
Alright, I think I'm good
Think I'm good... just in case!
Three doors!
Oh, hi!
Sentient object, you say?
Well! Here we go, then...
Hello? Would you like to talk?
I bet you would
Hello- oh, hi, dead body
How ya doing? How was you killed?
Ah, yes...
Squeak- uh oh....
Uh oh! Squeak
Oh, someone's not happy here
So, I gotta turn off-
I forgot, I need to turn off remote door control to this area
How do i do that again, I can't quite remember- (*crack* Dies not big Surprise)
AH! Ffffffff-
*Markimoo regains his composure with slow-motion karate moves*
Oooooooohkay
Memory access violation- okay, I think that's a sign
Right, i'm gonna end this episode here, 'case-
hoooooooooooly shit, okay, so
Uh, thank you everybody so much for watching, I think a break after that one,
My heart literally stopped for a full second there
That might have been one of the biggest jumpscares I've ever had, in like
my entire career of doing these horror games, but either way!
I'm gonna go lie down for a second, 'cause oh my god...
And I think some of you might need to lie down too, so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
Uh, I'll get back to this real soon, we'll have more regular episodes of this, don't you worry
Ugh, let me know how I did in the comments below,
Thanks again, and as always, I will see you-
In the next video!
Buh-bye!